[MUSIC]
Welcome folks, my name is Wil.
Welcome to our session today
talking about the experience going
from Stanford to Africa.
We have some really cool panelists
that I'm really excited to
be sharing space with today.
So once again, my name is Wil,
I'm one of the admission officers here at
the Stanford Graduate School of Business.
And today we're going to be talking about
what your journey could look like from
Stanford GSB to Africa to a career that is
fulfilling something you're excited by,
something that you feel that
you're able to make an impact and
that you're excited to do every day.
So to walk us through, we'll do some
brief introductions from our panelists.
From there, I have have some prepared
questions, and then we'll go to Q&A.
And so as you're all getting comfortable
in that Q&A box, that's the place,
you can go ahead and start asking
questions right now if you'd like.
I'll do my best and
incorporate them through the process and
then the end dedicated
just to your questions.
And we'll be here together for
about 55 minutes.
So, just to give you a brief
overview from Stanford,
you can literally go anywhere.
Code of the experience is, how can we
provide both the fundamental skills,
as well as those soft skills?
The things that you need to do to adapt,
so that you can be successful and thrive
regardless of where you find yourself
both geographically, industry wise.
Maybe you're creating a new industry
yourself maybe you have that vision.
We have 60 alumni clubs from around
the world over 30,000 alumni as well.
So wherever, you might be interested in,
there is going to be an alumnus or
alumna there or
someone that they might know.
So, as you think about the GSB community,
you are also a part of their extended
network and Stanford University.
Being able to say, I am a Graduate
of Stanford University also allows
you to connect with folks from
the engineering school public policy.
So many different fields of expertise that
can help you along the way to continue
growing along the way as a professional.
So, over 50 clubs and
organizations at the GSB as well.
One here that might be of particular
interest to many of you might
be the Africa Business Club.
And we are grace to have multiple
leadership members from that
organization as well as from
the Africa Business Forum.
One of our great events
on campus that we can,
we'll be able to talk
about in a little bit.
So, to kick us off, let's start,
we'll go left to right.
If we could start with before you there,
probably just settling back in.
So we have one panelist who will
be hopefully joining us shortly.
But until then maybe is Zweli,
can you get us started?
Tell us a little bit about
yourself of what you're doing now?
>> Hi everyone.
My name is Zweli,
I am originally from South Africa and so
I'm based in Africa right now.
So prior to GSB,
I worked in consulting my telecom and
currently I'm running a startup in
the clean tech space in South Africa.
Try to see if we can make the price
of getting solar and storage easy for
residual customers.
And super excited to be here.
>> And then,
did you know that you wanted to work
in Africa when you came to the GSB?
>> I wasn't 100% sure, right?
So, I knew that my long term plan
was to be back in the continent and
only graduated last year.
But what swayed the decision for me was
basically a class project style garage,
where we basically started doing user
interviews exploring it a bit more.
And that's where the concept
of the pod helps came.
And when it became clear that that's
something that energized me and
excited to be, even though it
was an industry, I didn't know.
I was in pretty thus going
back to Africa immediately.
>> We'll, definitely talk about startup
garage more [LAUGH] Later on cool.
Eugene, can you please
introduce yourself and
tell us a little bit about
what you're doing these days?
>> Hi, everyone.
Thank you so much for joining us today.
I'm Eugene Kenyan, and
currently dialling in from Nairobi, Kenya.
I worked in international development and
financial services,
investing in emerging
markets before the GSB.
And I'm currently working in Nigeria
infrastructure investing focused on
Africa.
And I knew from when I was joining
business school that I wanted to come back
to the continent.
>> Nice, and then before welcome you are,
[LAUGH] I have to say,
having worked with my previous colleagues,
Zipho you are legendary.
So glad that you're able to join us today.
Can you please introduce yourself in
a little bit about what you're doing
these days?
>> Yes, so hi, [LAUGH] And
thank you so much for having me.
I'm so glad that I could join
the conversation was important for
me to be here, you know my schedule.
[LAUGH] I'm sure you know.
But yeah, I'm a business leader,
I'm a businesswoman, so
I'm involved in many things.
But I guess primarily, around my
own business, I've got a team and
we actually work with leadership teams of
multinationals that are operating within
Africa, particularly South Africa.
And really helping them with
business recovery strategy, growth,
all kinds of topics around sustainability.
I also invest in early stage startups.
I've invested in a couple of GSB founded,
businesses, and stuff and
just involved in many things, but
I'm so glad to be in this panel.
And happy to answer your question that
I had just asked the others around
[LAUGH] The part to be at Stanford and
Africa are very similar to in Eugene.
My heart, I believe Africa space talent.
[LAUGH] This is home.
So, I went to Stanford knowing very well
that my goal is to have an impact on
the world, but
emerging from the African continent and
really showing the world
what Africa has to offer.
I do that in my day to day.
That's my reputation follows me.
[LAUGH] And I've seen many of our last
night in the sense of very excited to see
everyone again on this panel.
[LAUGH]
>> And Mbwana welcome.
I'm glad, so happy you're able to join us.
If you can do a brief introduction and
tell us a little bit about
what you're doing these days.
>> Thanks sorry I'm late.
I had a call that overang
that was important.
It was a deal that I have to do so and
I'm also having an exit conversation,
there's a lot happening.
It's really crazy on my end, I just
came back from Kenya trip I drove over.
So just a quick introduction.
Yeah, Mbwana Ali and am basically
from Tanzania where I now live.
I had an early career in the UK and
aerospace,
military flight testing and
some commercial that
I've moved over to
the West Coast with GSB 2007.
I think my class is often touted
as being very entrepreneurial.
[LAUGH] In a number of different ways,
I mean my roommate founded
[LAUGH] Duo design Sam Goldman,
which is a solar company that
scale in Africa quite a bit.
But also net chosen was, is only my class.
And more recently, our house was founded
by one of my classmates, Paul Davidson.
And the list is long,
there's a lot of others in our class.
So a couple of the entrepreneur class
that I did go to Microsoft after getting
from the GSB for a few years then
got went back to the Bay Area.
I couldn't deal with the Seattle rain,
came back to the Bay Area.
I did VC for a little bit in
early stage accelerator space.
From 2010, 2012 and
then moved back to Africa
2012 to start Savannah Fund.
And so
we're coming to the end of our first fund.
So obviously 2012 meaning that, for
a ten year fund,
2022 would be next year, right?
And so that's why I'm scrambling to get
some exits [LAUGH] for that first fund.
But our second fund has now been live,
we had a first of our second
fund three months ago which was
led by IFC, the World Bank.
And I believe we're the first seed fund
in Sub Saharan Africa they've backed.
They've done Egypt,
they've done Middle East,
I don't know if they've done
South Africa but not Sub Saharan Africa.
So yeah, so
on the second fund now, and yeah,
I've been doing venture capital now for
almost ten years on the African continent.
As I mentioned, I used to be in Kenya,
but I moved to Tanzania four years ago.
So I'm living in northern Tanzania,
near Kilimanjaro,
near some of the great parks like
Serengeti, Ngorongoro Crater.
And the reason I moved here is
because I can also drive to Nairobi.
So as I mentioned, I drove back on Tuesday
morning after spending two weeks in Kenya.
I always say that I have one foot
in Kenya, one foot in Tanzania.
I couldn't get vaccinated in Tanzania, so
I drove over to Kenya to get
vaccinated as an example.
Then I got my trip into it the rest
of Kenya so I was gone for a week.
So that's kind of a quick intro on myself,
happy to talk more and
discuss my experience.
>> And then did that you wanted to
come back to Africa after graduation,
or how was that for you?
>> Yes, the part of it's that Tanzanians
are quite well known for going home.
We've been lucky that Tanzania has had no
sort of administration that kind of or
the usual aspects of Africa that have
often scared away folks from returning.
Tanzania's been fairly peaceful.
We did have a small blip maybe
with our last president Magufuli,
who sadly passed away
allegedly of COVID in March.
And now we have the first
female president in the region.
And she's turned the ship around,
so I may have left Tanzania or
maybe Tanzania if they had the same
president for another four years.
But she's pro business, Samia.
And so yeah, I think that backdrop always
meant that Tanzanians are pretty happy to
stay and to come back.
But I would say that, yeah, like my
dad also, kind of family influence is
a big deal and my dad always said
don't come home without a plan.
And so I couldn't come back to Tanzania or
Africa without a presumption on the GSB.
It was better that I worked a little bit,
like I said at Microsoft and then VC.
It was only once I have a fund
raised to move back to Africa, but
that was my okay, bless this move,
because you've come up with a real plan.
>> Right.
>> And so that was a huge influence,
the timing of I guess VC
industry kind of early days,
plus my dad being comfortable that
I wouldn't come back and be a bum.
because that was basically my dad's
biggest fear, is that a lot of
people in Tanzania come back home and
they just kind of don't really do much.
And so that was definitely a big factor.
Then of course,
I'm sure the others have said this, but
the students make a massive impact,
has been really, really important for me.
And yeah, I didn't just move back to
Tanzania or Kenya, but I've gotten to
invest in Nigeria, and Uganda, Ghana,
South Africa, I'm there regularly.
Mozambique, I was there
just two three months ago.
Ethiopia is now emerging,
I did an investment there.
So the fact that VC gives me
this idea to come back and
build an Africa fund has
always fascinated me.
And the deeper you go,
the more you see, right?
And there's more out there.
There's still DRC,
there's a lot of countries
that I'm real interested to do more.
I guess if I was swimming back to,
say, Kenya or just Tanzania by itself,
I'm not really doing anything much beyond
that, I probably wouldn't have done it.
But I know that this is a global
game as well as regional in Africa.
But I still get to go back
to the Bay Area, right?
I'm planning my next trip in the fall when
obviously COVID hopefully, subsiding.
But yeah, I actually travel a lot
to the US because I have LPs there.
I don't miss the high rents of the Bay
Area, so I'm very happy where I am.
And also I traveled to Hong Kong and also
Europe as part of my LPs in those markets.
So actually, to be honest,
the biggest thing about going
back was I'm actually more
global as a result than if I
stayed in the Bay Area, I think.
So I feel like I really
utilized my education and
my quest to go global by doing Africa VC.
So that was the right opportunity for me.
>> Zipho, speaking of going global,
I know you are also very well traveled.
Can you tell me a little bit about how
that has impacted the way you view
kind of leadership development and
kind of your profession in Africa?
>> Yes, yes, no, most definitely,
most definitely.
I've had the privilege of having
traveled now 37 countries, 37.
>> [CROSSTALK]
>> Exactly, my last trip was just
before the first lockdown hit South Africa
in February and it hits us in March.
So I'm really looking forward
to traveling again more soon.
But I'll be honest, I mean, I come from
very impoverished background, right?
And for someone like me, traveling was not
something that was ever a norm, right,
in terms of where I come from,
and my community etc.
And for me, having an opportunity to
really go to Stanford, right, and
just spend time with people
from all over the world, right?
It was a big wake up call for me.
But not just that, I mean,
just that opportunity of being there.
It's so encouraged that you actually
you be part of the world's oyster.
And I made the most of it, right?
So, when I was in Stanford, I mean,
I did my exchange program into China.
I did another another program to Russia,
a global study trip.
I went with classmates or
colleagues did another program, Brazil,
all over the world, right?
So, [LAUGH] I mean, those were
the opportunities that I was able to get,
that really opened my eyes and
really opened my mind in so many ways.
And it also encouraged me.
As much as I'm passionate, and I always
have been passionate about the African
continent, it really spurred me to make
the decision to actually move to Spain.
Learn Spanish from scratch, [LAUGH] and
work for the world's biggest retail group.
I was in an international director role,
and I ended up traveling.
By the time I came back
to the African continent,
I'd worked across six
different continents.
I'm never going to go to Antarctica,
right?
[LAUGH] But that opportunity,
I'm still African at heart.
That opportunity opened my mind,
because I started realizing that there's
different ways of leading, right?
And right now the premise
of how we lead and
the whole education system to be honest,
right?
And even the workplace, etc,
it's influenced by one system of thinking,
one system of thoughts, right?
And what I really appreciated
about being at Stanford is that it
really opened our minds a lot to the fact
that there's more to the world, right?
And there's also a lot
more places to learn from.
So we learned from whether it's
the first or developing world and
all kinds of for the world.
So then when you're talking about
leadership, I think for me having come
back to the African continent,
I've learned and I've realized, right?
I mean, I mentioned that I spend my days a
lot with multinationals, the CEOs of these
big giants, right, helping them
make these businesses sustainable.
And one of the things that encouraged
them is it's really important to lead
from what is authentic to you as a leader.
Right?
Because you cannot be someone else,
you can't try and
fit into someone else's scripts, right?
That's not who you are,
that's not your core.
And one of the things about us being
from the African continent as some
of the people that are listening is that
there's a certain ethos of leadership that
is part of our DNA from so
many generations.
That's what the world needs right now.
So how do we leverage that, right?
For all of us, as other leaders in
different parts of the world do the same
because then what ends up happening is
the world benefits from that, right?
And that's what I enabled leaders to do.
Even the leaders that I work with
that are not from South Africa, or
from different parts of
the African continent.
And they're coming here to have impact and
drive businesses, and
I say to them this them there's a premise.
How do you think about bringing what you
know, but how do you think about honoring
the best of what comes from
while you are here basically?
But if you ask me,
whether it's self awareness, right?
Or that level of that ability to
challenge yourself and say, but
what is authentic and
what is real to you as a leader?
It really comes from how I was challenged
in my own journey in the MBA, right?
As much as I was happy with my
progress and my achievements and
I was keen to learn more, there I was
really challenged to really grow and
ask myself what kind of leader am I?
And then what does that look like when
you then go out to the world, right?
Which is what I did, and
also what I loved and
I reflect back fondly on is that I was
never encouraged to follow any scripts.
I was really encouraged.
I feel like for me whenever I reflect
about my journey with Stanford,
they encouraged me to be the best
version of myself that I could be.
Whatever that is, right?
And stuff, and so today yes,
I've always been entrepreneurial.
I mean since I was five years old I was
running businesses for survival, for
sustenance, then fun, then everything.
And then yesterday I had businesses but
it's something that I'm realizing now
what kind of intrapreneur I am, right?
And stuff, and then also having
the opportunity to create jobs and
really create opportunities for
young people to work with.
Think about it, in what space do you get
an opportunity to get access to leaders of
multinationals, right?
And stuff, and so being able to create
that opportunity for young talent is
something for me that's been important and
then that's been really, really critical.
And I think the last one thing that I'll
also mention is that one of the benefits
of also just seeing different
parts of the world, right?
Is I think it really helped me
appreciate the strengths, right?
Appreciate and honor the strengths
of my journey, where I come from,
because sometimes people
tell half the story.
We talk about the things,
the struggle, ladies and get them out.
But there's lessons from the difficulty
and there's lessons from that growth.
And let's be honest, right?
Look at what happened to 2020.
It put trauma in all of us.
Everybody, everybody, and
we had to ask ourselves,
where have you faced difficulty,
where have you faced struggle?
And guess what, we know the scripts
we have the answers just because of
the legacy of where we come from
as a continent, as a people.
This is the time that the world needs to
learn from us and I'm very passionate
about just making sure that that's
taken to the rest of the world, right?
As much as possible.
>> Yeah, and I love the way
you talk about being empowered
to embrace kind of what is there and
share it and
like find that strength in
that place of who you are.
So that's amazing.
Kind of bridging from something you
said before this is for Julian Eugene.
She was talking about like challenging
the way that you see yourself,
challenging the way you see the world.
Kind of on the threshold of your
GSB experience as you're returning
to the continent, can you talk a little
bit about maybe an experience or
class that has challenged you in that way?
I know there's a couple of questions
in the Q&A box about were there any
classes in particular,
what were some of the things that helped
you see kind of yourself in new ways?
So maybe Zwelihle we can start with you
and then Eugene will follow with you,
>> Sean, [COUGH] now thanks for
the question.
So for me, I think a lot of it was
trying to explore what it meant very
experientially to be an entrepreneur
in startup business, right?
So my prior background was working
in consulting that in industry,
consumer telecoms, I'd always started
things like organizations in high schools,
smaller businesses.
But I would have never used the term
entrepreneur to define myself at all and
not to kind of show why.
But I think the idea of then now
having basically uninhibited
what does it look like to start
something from absolutely nothing.
So concepts interviews, trying to
interview users in South Africa in
the value recruits people and put things
together made me realize how much of those
skills I might have learned, even though
I wouldn't have fully appreciated it.
And therefore how much of that can be
a very big part of like the career and
choices that I've chosen.
And I think that it would
have been very hard for
me to make that transition
outside of that.
So it is both the classes, but
also the idea that there's this
big theme at GSB around doing
something that really matters to you.
But also challenging yourself to say,
what does it look like when you
start this from zero to one, right?
So my prized business consulting was
like helping big companies grow and
there's a certain skill and
thinking set, yeah.
But that idea of training across kind
of people management, marketing,
functional areas, zero to one for
me was very kind of impactful.
And that was both in the classes but
also in the experiences interacting
judge the classmates,
the kinds of speakers that come to school.
And that had a big, big impact, very
direct impact which just made me choose
a different career choice
immediately during the pandemic.
But that was like a big impact for me.
>> Yes, and then Eugene,
how about yourself?
Like what are some of the ways that GSB
has helped you challenge kind of the way
you see yourself in the world?
>> Thank you very much, Will.
I think I'll speak to two things.
I think the first really transformative
thing that happened to me at
the GSB was I learned
how to embrace failure.
Because I think one of the things MBA does
really, the program really stretches you,
I think beyond your imagination.
And there's so
many opportunities in an MBA program,
you think you can do everything.
So I remember I really
loaded up my summer.
Last summer I wanted to do two,
three internships and travel the world and
go explore the startup space in Nigeria.
And I remember my last assignment
I just wasn't able to complete it,
I was just too stretched and
I didn't know what to do.
And I just reached out to
the Stanford C team that was
working on that internship program.
And I told them you know what,
I don't think I'll be able to complete
my tasks in this last assignment.
And I think for
me the reaction that is cool,
because I initially thought I'm
going to get punished for these,
I committed to something
that I can't complete.
But I think the way
the school reacted to that,
they may even have put me
in touch with an alumni.
And I got a lot of help around that in
terms of accepting when you feel you've
taken on too much and accepting
failure and actually learning from it.
And I remember one thing this
particular alumni told me and
he's actually one of the biggest
investors in the continent.
He told me, he doesn't invest in
anyone who has never made a mistake.
And I was like,
mistakes are part of learning.
And thus that is not something I hadn't,
you come to GSB,
maybe you're a bit of a perfectionist,
you're used to getting everything, right?
And I think for me, this was one time that
I realized I can't always be right and I
can't always do everything by myself, and
I should be open to reaching out for help.
And I'd say the other thing
is taking a bit more risk.
So going to business school initially,
imagine I want to go to this school,
and then come back and work for one of
the biggest investors in the African
continent, the more established names.
And then you go to Stanford and you're
exposed of both types of businesses and
you realize how this is a lot
more exciting to work with.
Sort of smaller new businesses that are
still experimenting their business model.
And so that's how I ended up deciding to
go to Africa 50 which is barely four years
old and just try to figure out their
strategy around the continent.
And I'm testing a lot of new things.
So it feels even though I'm working for
a big firm,
it still feels very startup issue, I think
that's something I picked up the GSB.
And eventually how I see that panning out
is I'd probably be trying to do a fund in
a couple of years down the line.
>> And
then Eugene you mentioned Stanford seed,
can you tell us a little bit
more about that group, please?
>> Yeah, Stanford seed for
me was actually one of the reasons I
was really keen about going to Stanford
especially because I knew I want to
come back to the continent right after.
So this is an entrepreneurship initiative
that supports a close to 1,000
businesses now in Africa.
And so Stanford seed takes African
entrepreneurs through an entrepreneurship
training program to help
them scale their businesses.
And they do allow Stanford students
both from the business school as well as
other schools to intern at Stanford Seed,
and Stanford pretty much meets the cost.
So it's a it's actually a really
good way for you to try and
learn about a part of the continent
that you haven't been,
because many of us grew up in our,
South Africa.
And that's all you know about Africa,
maybe you know your neighboring countries.
But maybe you've never worked to lived in
North Africa and Stanford seed gives you
that opportunity as an MBA student about
your first and your second summers.
You could actually do two different
internships in different parts of Africa.
And get to sort of increase your knowledge
and network about the continent.
So for me that was one of the best things
about Stanford for an African student and
also a very strong partner for the Africa
business club in terms of funding,
helping out with events and networks.
So it really truly makes experience for
an African a bit more wholesome.
>> Africa business club you just said,
it is selfishly one of my favorite groups,
they have such amazing people.
And we were on a panel recently,
and they're talking about how,
this just the celebration of what it meant
to be African at the GSB at Stanford.
And just the way the energy of all
the panelists lit up was amazing,
and I know we have a folks here
who were involved in the club.
I'll open this up to whoever would
someone like to talk a little bit about
Africa business club?
What it does, maybe any experiences
that just really spoke to you from it?
>> Yeah, I can go, because, I mean,
now I'm seeing how dated I am but
just to give you a context Africa students
in the jesting wasn't that high when I was
there, right?
And I guess some questions
here were people asking,
what is the Stanford alumni
network done for you, etc.
That wasn't a big, to be honest that
was a big decision I had to make.
Do I go to the West Coast or
some of the East Coast schools around
who's got the better Africa network?
When I go to Stanford, and
I was joining the clubs,
I joined the black Business Association
as well as the ABC, but they were not,
ABC wasn't that big was
kind of seen as sports.
But then I've seen it over the years,
particularly after I left.
So this is kind of the back question
of what has the GSB done for
me after I've left?
I almost feel I've got so
much out of it the last at least five or
six years that I did even that, because
of course when you graduate from the GSB,
those first three years
depends what you're doing.
But I was always at Microsoft and
trying to find my feet,
I wasn't going back to Africa yet.
Not in Africa, as I mentioned.
But looking back on it one of
the things that has happened is,
I've had two GSB case studies,
done going after businesses.
Go links of big finance and
the Bitcoin crypto space,
that I kicked that was written up in 2014,
right?
So I know crypto hot now or
kind of was hot last year this year, but
it was also hot in the previous wave 2014,
15, so I had a GSB case and
it was the first crypto case in the GSB.
And it was also one of the first
African startup cases, right?
And then more recently, I think it is
2017,18 airobotics a drone company,
and as I used to work in aerospace from
a bio, so I was an ag tech drone company,
both African cases but also there was
a class has become more popular now.
I don't know how it is with in
recent years the [INAUDIBLE] and
a few other professors are doing the
merchant rockets entrepreneurship class.
These case studies and there was an
emerging markets entrepreneurship class,
when I was there, but I've gone to
co teach those classes right, or
guest lecture, which I love with
my own case studies of course.
There's two I mentioned,
which has also led to a pipeline of
students who have interned for me.
So for example, Lauren Dunford, she
interned for me and then also a company
called the second Linux, then just
raise series A last month, right?
And then also I have Steve as my board, so
he's on my IC, so Investment Committee.
So that of a woven certain GSB is going to
be woven into what I do in my fund,
in that I have students that intern for
me, and
I've done well funded companies that
are funded, and I've got professors.
We're also both invested in my company
in my fund and so it's kind of like so
I can't help I go back to campus, because
I just get all this feedback of talent.
But yeah, I know that the Africa
business forum has become very big,
it didn't exist when I was there, right?
So to be honest, I'm kind of jealous
with some of the other students who
have been there later than I have been.
But when I was at GSB,
it was not that big.
I was running to HBS and
board conferences, but
I'm very excited to hear to see
that not only is the ABC grown, and
as a conference Africa Forum has
become bigger have been twice.
But also that there's more students and
Africa fellowship,
I believe that is still there.
I believe Tanzania and the second
Tanzania have [INAUDIBLE] nine days,
was the first one to get that I think,
out of Tanzania,
I saw the target of more,
packing of Africans coming to the GSB.
But yeah, just going to do some
nuggets around how I've used GSB
to help me really join into my work.
And one of the things I
want to mention is that,
one unexpected aspect of my kind of GSB I
didn't realize it would help me, was my
favorite class was actually the nonprofits
class run by Bill Meet at the time.
He's now retired,
he was an ex McKinsey consultant and
there a lot of stuff in nonprofit
consulting with McKinsey, but
he actually told me yeah, he actually
had a really amazing performance class.
That I didn't think I would use, but I'm
using almost every day because I'm a board
chairman Africa's biggest entertainment
store non-profit global kids.
Which is 70 billion Africans, and
I literally I'm using everything I learned
from that class daily as a board chair.
Obviously, board chair of
a nonprofit is a big deal, right?
For example, I'm not hiring a CEO,
compensate the CEO and
I'm referring back to my
notes about how the nonprofit
compensation is very different for
profit side of things.
I've always been a VC by day, but by night
I mentioned this nonprofit a board member
and so I've learning a lot from that.
Yeah, so that was probably one of my
favorite classes, it's been very useful.
Other fun fact, Bill,
told me not to do VC.
He said when you go back to Africa,
don't do this it's not going to work.
I didn't take his advice on that one,
but I'm still using his knowledge and
experience from nonprofits in Africa.
So that doesn't mean everything you learn
from the GSB is going to directly apply or
the question I get requests
directly it makes sense.
Because of course back then
there was an African VC right,
there was that emerging market wasn't
that VC was just saying, Silicon Valley,
US May be China, India and
sometime Europe.
But obviously fast forward to today 15
years later almost, he sees Africa is
growing really amazingly,
there's a lot of startup activity.
I mean, some of the others have mentioned
that have been involved in the sector.
It's going to start to mature more and
more.
So Bill was wrong for his time, but he was
definitely has some timeless gems from
this nonprofit class that
I'm still using today.
>> Thanks, and then Zippo,
I know you had a leadership position
as well in Africa business council.
I'll turn to you in a second.
There was one question as we're
talking about fellowships.
There was a question earlier
in the Q&A box about funding,
the GSB in the education and
so we have evolved over time.
So now we practice a need based
plan financial aid process.
So basically the philosophy is,
we're taking a look at things
like prior income assets.
So that we can make sure that
the folks who need the most support
are getting the most financial aid.
So that they can come to the GSB and
make this a reality.
This year we also launched a new
program called the BOLD fellows fund.
And so this is in recognition that for
many people,
you're not the only one
going through this journey.
You might be supporting family or
there might be other expenses.
There might be a dedication to
diversifying the conversations and
the dialogue that you're surrounded by.
And so there is an additional set
of money that you can apply for to
help close that gap even further between
financial aid and the cost of attendance.
So lots of different ways that we're
looking to support our students, and
there's also a bunch of different and
creative ways once you're here.
We have a financial aid office that
works very closely with our students.
So, if you have questions
once you're here,
you can always set up appointments
with them as a student.
And we will do our best to figure out what
could be a life path that makes the most
sense to get you through
this GSB experience.
And so,
from that segue to follow up, Zippo,
I'm going to turn it back to you as one
of our kind of former leaders of the ABC.
Can you tell us a little
bit about that experience?
>> Yes, most definitely,
you can see leadership for
somebody that's very close to my heart.
So I saw that the leaders of
the African business camp committee,
I was also an international committee and
a few other things, right?
Just because I think it's important
the world is your oyster.
But from an African
business care perspective,
I think there's a few things, right?
For me, it was definitely an opportunity,
one of the campus, just had that intimacy
that you're able to have, right,
with your colleagues, also with people.
It's not just, I think also we
need to open our minds, right?
When you talk about Africa business,
people that are interested in that it's
not just people coming from Africa, right?
It's actually people even from other parts
of the world that are really passionate
about building relationships and
connections with people that
are from that continent or might have
a passion for doing business in Africa.
But the biggest sweet benefits that no one
didn't mention here is because when would
you then get to be in a leadership
position I guess with the Africa business
club, you get to choose
whichever African leader or
any African interested either you
want to advise, so and so [LAUGH].
And they come, right, and
this sample class is very small by design.
It's very intimate, right?
So what you end up doing is,
you invite the president [LAUGH], and
he comes in and he has lunch with us.
Those are things that
peppered at Stanford that,
what is it the way of getting
access to someone like this?
But it happen, so I just use it
as an opportunity to network and
build relationships with influential
presidents, influential business leaders.
Because they come, they also appreciate
the opportunity of spending time with
us when we are at Stanford.
I also want to encourage people
to think beyond your class.
So, for example, I mentioned earlier
that one of my passions [LAUGH] is,
they say you should never make
these kinds of decisions.
Like best in any stage businesses,
because well the chances of
failure are quite high, right?
But it's something I'm passionate about.
So I do it as a way to give back.
It's not at all my primary business, but
if I then look back and I think, wait,
what are some of the investments that
I've made over the years, right?
One of them is a GSB alumni
from my class 2014, and
he's starting an aviation business,
I mean, one of the first and
cutting edge airlines in Pan-Africa,
right?
And they launching this year the first
airplane and I've invested in him for so
many years that I think six, seven years.
Then another one is another again,
Nigerian alumni to a FinTech startup,
right, now driving it from the US.
Another one is another GSB alumni
also half African half American, and
he's actually built a business that
is the first quality education for
the middle class and
is rolling this across Africa.
And I also invested in someone like him
early in the day and he is from I mean,
he used to be my mentor,
when I was wet behind the ears, right?
[LAUGH].
And then post Stanford,
when I heard his vision,
I went and I supported him.
So, what I was trying to say is that,
the network that you get, right, so
when you thinking about that African
business network, it goes across,
it actually goes across generations.
It also goes across countries, right?
And even recently,
I've looked into doing seed investments
to some Stanford people in China.
But it's not the same when I'm at
a passion that comes, I'm like wait,
I get to see the impact much
closer to me at home, right?
And even I've known him for
many years is also one of my mentees, so
very proud of him when he was
in his intern at Stanford.
But also just what he's building I just
think there's all those opportunities
that, those amazing people,
we get to spend time with each other,
get to know each other much better.
And also the networks, even some people
would refer clients to my business, right?
It would be people from Stanford,
okay, from different parts of,
different generations of Stanford.
Some of them I've never even met,
they just know of me, or have heard of me.
Then they refer clients
to my organization.
So I just think that
the network that you get
with the Africa business
connects goes beyond that.
That actually, I mentioned earlier that
one of the programs that was really
influential for me when I was at Stanford
was the COVID experiences program, right?
I mean, it opened my mind, right, and
I spent time overseas in immersing myself.
So I have now weighed in
created that opportunity.
There's literally a current Stanford
students that's been selected to
come work for my organization.
This literally in a month, yeah,
because we're just so busy.
And we are hiring so aggressively.
We're looking for talent, but I just
thought, let me open the opportunity and
he applied and so he'll be helping us.
And Kennedy by background, speak Spanish.
Imagine that kind of opportunity
that he's now having access to.
Even learning about business in Africa,
so that's what it is for me,
it goes, if get global, right?
And then it's also up to us what you
want to do with those opportunities,
depending on what your
aspirations are in life, right?
And I also want to say I think in my head
the processing speed as I'm talking, but
just listen to our conversations,
I can hear also people are thinking.
Wait, this one is an intrapreneur
this one is an intrapreneur.
Wait, this one is a VC, right?
All options are available for you beyond
that, because one of the things also when
I was going into Stanford as I wait,
is it only for entrepreneurs, right?
Yes, I'm an entrepreneur at hearts but
I never was like, yes, that's my ultimate,
so, but I challenged myself
when I went in and said no.
Which part is it going to be?
And then what I loved is that, when we
then met different business leaders,
like at the beginning it was a lot of
entrepreneurs and the impressive ones.
The ones you read about in the papers
all the time, they were coming and
sitting with you in the class and
telling you their cases.
But as more and
more came I started finding what I could,
I see myself as a business leader, right,
as much as I'm passion about
intrapreneurship, I'm business leader.
And I started seeing people like me who
Iike business leaders in terms of how
they made the choices,
how they fill their entities.
And I started seeing that no,
no intrapreneurship is not one way, right?
Like the book of,
where you have the trash and
that it's like you're the one
who takes out the trash.
There's that storyline, right?
It's just you and service.
There's many ways of building it and
stuff, right, from the garage to a much
more structured environment which I've
tried to do even from the first day,
it's always been a very, very classic.
Fundamentals of business design.
But obviously growing aggressively, right?
Especially, even in a pandemic, and
just being accelerated with the growth,
you start seeing so
many things are breaking, right?
And so Eugene,
you touched me when you said,
was like I go to the books,
right, and the notes.
I keep saying to myself,
Zipha, go to the notes,
[LAUGH] because this stuff is there,
right?
So the classes that stand out for me,
managing group growing enterprises,
I keep adding to go to the notes but
everything I learned from there is so
relevant and stuff.
There was also a class
that changed my life.
They say when you are at Stanford, there's
actually two, but they say when you're at
Stanford, usually there's just
that one class that gets to you.
And I know there's touchy feely, right?
I'm sure someone will get to that.
That was a transformative experience from
an interpersonal growth perspective.
But definitely there
was one with pop jaws,
I believe it was issues in leadership.
And it was two weeks.
It was only two weeks but it was one
of the hardest classes to get into.
In two weeks, my life was transformed,
in two weeks.
But it's because of how he just
that ability that he cared so
much about helping us grow as leaders.
I mean, he played a big bank in Australia,
he'd been a former dean at Stanford.
He'd achieved so much in his life but
the fact that he was passionate about
developing us and just that ability
of really helping us all introspect,
and he said, look, I've read and
I know the best insights on leadership.
I've narrowed it down to the ones
that I think are transformative from
generation to generation.
That material for
me was absolutely priceless, right?
Because then it's allowed me to then
have a lens on leadership that is more
universal, but
also it empowered me, right?
The leaders that I work
with will think about it.
Well, the people who
are leading businesses today,
I'm in my early 30s, right?
They are in the north of,
your multinationals,
I'm not going to offend anyone.
But they are in the north of,
whether it's late 40s or 50s.
I mean, that's the people
leading corporations today.
But I have the confidence and the power
to actually be able to help them multiply
their bottom line and they come
back here and, yeah, why is that?
Why is that?
It's because I was really really pushed,
challenged myself to say bring something
that's different to this world
that doesn't exist yet, right?
And it's there on campus,
you know the record, right?
Well, and certainly on campus, right?
Dedicated to the things that
haven't happened yet and
the people who are about to dream them up.
And imagine looking at that everyday,
everyday and
it eventually hit me years
after I left Stanford.
And I genuinely feel that everything
that I do is I'm literally bringing up
the things that haven't happened yet.
And I'm one of the people who's crazy
enough to dream them up, right?
[LAUGH] That's the difference.
After this,
don't be surprised if I go out to make
a T-shirt that says go to the notes.
Just as a reminder, go to the notes,
y'all have it already.
Eugene and [INAUDIBLE],
I saw the two of you smile when Zipha
mentioned interpersonal dynamics.
Did either of you take that course?
Any thoughts on- Yeah,
as I took interpersonal dynamics,
so touchy feely and for content for
folks like that though.
This is very strange class when
twice a week you have six hours
unstructured with 12 basically
random classes and two facilitators.
And you guys just left there to just be,
and to deal and to interact?
And it's just very interesting because
inevitably, it kind of brings to the fore,
the things that are most important
in both understanding yourself,
what motivates you.
But also how you interact with
different people and therefore,
how to then kind of influence them.
But not from a hey, I'm the lead,
I'm going for A to B,
just truly listening and understanding.
And also having a very deep sense of wait,
here's the set of experiences I've had,
this is how they shape how I see things,
is how other people see things and
how to balance that out, right?
And that for me was kind of super
impactful, and felt like I learned a lot
from that, and then also became a much
stronger version of myself from that so.
And so bridging from that,
maybe kind of connecting to
a question that Isabel has asked.
I know we've been trying to weave in some
of the parts of questions throughout.
But something between as you're
challenging yourself, and as you're making
that transition and return or have been
working on the continent for a while.
How have some of these realizations
helped you work through challenges that
maybe you hadn't anticipated before?
So can you tell us,
think about some of that connection?
How did it prepare you for that?
They kind of give one, right?
So one was around, again, for
me kind of a lot more by sample
experiences about being entrepreneurial.
But there's a bunch of things
I'd never done before, right?
I never tried to hire people.
And I never experienced almost pain, joy,
scariness of talking to someone being
excited, and then seeing that drop off and
still feel like things must go on.
And I was trying to do that,
trying to recruit people for
a project in South Africa,
find exciting, energy, find exciting.
But trying to find people who
are dedicated want to work with that kind
of [INAUDIBLE].
And even just the realization and
learning from trying to recruit classmates
from across the street, from other
kind of schools, or in your class and
try to see what that fit looks
like has been so valuable.
But also knowing when it works,
when it doesn't work, but
still having the confidence to say I
need to take this from A to B to C to D.
I'd take that in any case.
Has been very, very useful for
me that transition then pretended to be
someone's boss and tried to hire them.
And that's been kind of one thing that's
been just a very big thing that I would
have never thought about.
But the idea of having to
recruit teammates, and
trying to kind of put together resources,
and trying to get that across,
has been very kind of valuable with that.
The other part I think is
something that has touched on,
a similar experience as where a lot of
kindof actually some seed entrepreneurs of
GSB lecturers have been investors or
advisors, etc.
But then the comfort and
confidence of saying.
So there was a class where someone's like,
okay,
now you're doing energy from South Africa.
Why not just email Elon Musk?
I'm like, what do you mean?
Let's start thinking,
[INAUDIBLE] that audacity?
And that daring is the same kind of,
why wouldn't you, right?
And that you've proven yourself enough
to be able to have those conversations.
Sometimes it works,
sometimes it doesn't work.
That has been also super kind of
impactful, and has been critical
in this kind of journey that I've
been through right now post school.
So coming back to that,
the things that haven't happened yet and
the people who are about to dream
them up kind of spirit and mentality.
I know we're starting to close in on time,
this has flown by.
So as we start to wrap up,
and maybe each one of you can
take a turn at this question is.
As we start to wrap this session,
any tips,
words of wisdom or advice for
folks out there who might be
considering kind of a future
going from Stanford to the GSB,
whether that's application, as a leader.
What is a piece of advice that maybe
you would have given yourself,
kind of a younger you, and that other
folks can learn from along the way?
So we'll take a moment, think about that.
And then whoever wants to
jump in can get us started.
I think I'm happy to go first on this one.
So I think, when I remember my
time doing the application,
I think Almost at no particular point did
I ever think I had a chance of getting in.
So I think I was just in case because I
think when you speak to people trying to
apply.
People tend to focus a lot on I didn't
get a perfect GPA in undergrad,
I didn't come from this industry.
Maybe I'm a bit too old and
people tend to focus a lot on why
they think they wouldn't get in.
I think the reality is that there isn't
a single applicant who's going to tick all
the boxes, right.
So I think our focus on the things,
you strong,
I don't know the things
you can actually change.
So, if you didn't have a very good
undergrad GPA try get a good score HD
image.
If you're not very confident about
your ability to write a great essay.
Then maybe get amazing recommenders and
spend time building a relationship with
recommenders where they get to know
you beyond just you as an employee or
a student.
So doing focus, I'd say focus on
the things you could actually improve.
And don't do so
much time lamenting about the things
you don't think you're very good at.
Because I think at the end of
the day with once you go to school,
you realize everyone had that
dent in the application or
a thought is not is going to
stop them from getting in.
But they eventually did.
>> I can go next?
>> Yeah,
>> This maybe I'm not quite sure how this
next class would come in but
assuming everything's back
to normal with COVID etc.
I mean don't forget to go across the
street when you go to Stanford like work
when you go there and you should,
it's easy to be on campus all the time.
But Silicon Valley is an amazing place.
I mean, the first job I focus very
hard on the clubs and academics and
all kinds of changes how they
do the curriculum now, but
I spend a lot of my second
year going off campus.
Meeting me at the time when I was
at Facebook was very new, right.
A lot of my classmates
were hired into Facebook.
There was a lot of unfinished activity.
I don't want to change providers but
it still be the center.
I want to finish it for a while.
So, go across the street, not just campus
but to Palo Alto Mountain view, etc.
Cisco.
I wish I did more of that.
But I think when I was there,
I did enough of it.
And it helped build some connections that
were very valuable beyond just the campus.
Yeah.
So I think that's something that I wish
all students are realizing they go there.
It's like you need to really take
advantage of the Silicon Valley to
the amazing place.
It's a very magical place I think they
need to be so, take advantage of that.
>> Yeah.
And I'm happy to add from my side,
I think I'll be filtered in what I
say because I also say that
the interview final round panel.
So we're not allowed to give any advice.
So this is not advice, [LAUGH] But
I think the big thing for me is this is
probably one of the most transformative
experiences in most people's lives, right.
And I didn't believe that when they
told me before I thought they were
making it up.
And I felt that way,
since even though I've had so
many amazing things happen
to my life since then.
So, one of the things that
really helped me back then,
is that when I started applying, I
started asking people to read the essays.
They keep saying no put the efforts and
I put months of effort
months of effort into it.
And so I really encourage people to say if
this is one of the big opportunities in
your life, right?
You might want to put in effort,
[LAUGH] so
that you make your best bets because it's
1000s and 1000s of people trying but
there's a spot for you, but
you need to make that effort.
Did you really need to do it?
And I'm really glad I made that effort.
And yes,
I got into a number of MBA programs.
But Stanford for
me was always my first choice and I'm so
glad that I made that effort
to just apply, right.
And put in the effort as much as possible.
But I think that's important.
I also wanted to talk to when I was
talking about which is he was also
talking about networking across, right.
I wanted to also mention that just
going across the building, right.
Stanford business school, it's the rest
of the school is there, right?
And for me growing as a leader at Stanford
gave me an option to what is the thing you
choose what you want to
do with your experience?
For me growing as a leader is
not just about the education or
the business classes.
So by the time I left, I attend
a class at the medical school, right?
Literally where I was with
doctors during my MBA.
Did a class at the acting school.
So I literally had to
physically move my body.
And to the class at the music school where
I literally had to stretch my vocals and
on the Sports Academy side and some
programs they all within, but my MBA and
some of them may be negotiated
to get credits for them.
So I just think it's so much that you can
do a cross, beyond the business school.
But I really encourage people to think of
the experience as this is an opportunity
to immerse myself in an environment that
has Silicon Valley right next door, right?
It has a pedal out.
So then there's also
the California pods today and
then should I also mention the river,
all right?
On that though, it's just the people
at Stanford, excellent, amazing.
Yeah, so that's what I encourage people
to do work out in your application,
and then prepare yourself and just to
have fun and meet some amazing people.
>> And to that point,
first week of August,
we are hosting an application week.
Where I'll be hosting a series of events
to help you understand our application
process and
help you put your best foot forward.
And really go ahead and take us home
>> So,
I think for me it's kind of like
religion point that people made, right.
So earlier around being your most
authentic self someone said,
if you have a comfortable with
more than five people in the world
reading your essays is
probably not personal enough.
And the kind of the motivation is
that there's a really high chance,
this really kind of low,
kind of acceptance rate.
So, if people were trying to fill
that class with a perfect candidate,
they probably do that ten times over.
What really was the distinguish you,is
saying what really reflecting on yourself
and digging deep and
what's most important there.
And then tailoring that to be
the most true version of yourself.
Both when you add Stanford, but
also kind of reflecting, honestly,
while you're kind of before while you're
at Stanford and afterwards, right?
Because at the end of the day, that's way
the biggest power you have will have and
then that's also where
the fulfillment happens.
Whether or not it is conventional,
successful or not.
If you feel you've kind of followed
the path that's in you, and
you've used that time to reflect, that's
probably the most important thing for me,
at least when you're kind of looking at
the essays and the application process.
>> It all starts with you.
So thank you so
much to everybody who joined us.
Thank you to our panelists.
Until our next time, if you haven't done
so already, please feel free to jump on my
Stanford.MBA with a quick little kind of
questionaire will be able to help create
a dashboard for you, populate some
event that might be of interest and
keep you updated in the new on
what is happening around the GSP.
So, once again from Stanford,
from all over panelist all over
the continent, thank you so much for
spending time with us today,
we hope to see you soon and be safe.
Have a great rest of your week, everyone.
[MUSIC]